josy oui patron appelez-moi 117 oss 117
n'êtes vous pas le meilleur
[Musique]
je vous répondrai oui ce serait de la
prétention
[Musique]
je vous répondrais non ça serait la
bêtise
hubert que savez vous de l'afrique
les africains sont joyeux sympathique il
devance bien
très bonne analyse super je compte sur
vous aucun malentendu nos amis voit du
racisme partout le président vous restez
pas être parfait le temps d'enfiler mon
costume colonial blanc clair pourquoi
c'est clair
dans quelques jours je donne un bal
présidentielle au palais pour fêter
l'indépendance dans l'est pendant mon
souhait on m'a dit ça
ouais 717 je vous présente près 7000 1
117 et le vrai l'unique la légende
ça allait très bientôt car toujours en
saut lui cette mission vous allez me l'a
menée tous les deux les rebelles veulent
balayer le président d'en bas un bruit
par mbaye panini a pris du retard c'est
pour ça que j'ai contre prince est payé
en main
puis quand même un hic est un hic de
taille vous êtes une femme est une femme
présidence
je suis agent secret à nourrice
[Musique]
c'est un quiproquo
tout est sous contrôle
c'est un peu fatigué m'enfin il va se
ressaisir
pas mal non
et là il a tout foutu en l'air je suis à
8,6 et un plan va falloir qu'ils
m'expliquent
j'ai un peu de mal à saisir la stratégie
chaque espèce la plus dangereuse soit
elle à son prédateur je suis lent
prédateurs
vous n'avez plus bas là oui mais eux ne
savent pas